[Music]
whatever this is i don't got
time for it okay our daddy killed that
reporter you got a sick mind jesse
that's exactly what i've been saying to
him it's obvious i'm talking on
daddy you don't know daddy as well as
you think you do judy need a ride yeah
i'll take one then get one
that can't shoot worth of i'll
shoot you go to your room right now this
damn family has everything in the world
but you can't just all get along
everybody in the church knows that your
husband is a joke
you rollerblade it's an exercise i do to
keep swole
the is that it's daddy's phone last
night reminded me of old times i set
them up you knock them down
knock them down means kill and kill
means murder and murder causes death
what kind of baptism is this today is
the day that tj is going to be born
again dj who's ready to meet tj 2.0
we were attacked
don't get involved i need some fellas to
help handle some business down in
memphis tennessee
yeah gregory is there another
memphis well actually there is this
little ancient city all right well we're
not going to ancient egypt you
we have been having some epic hangs oh
we sure have
this thank god proud today i can do that
if you come along the impoverished
family are ready to take therefore
they're so excited over such a small
amount yeah like 50 000 is like barely
any money poor people love money y'all
you